こんにちははじめ社長です8月末ぐらいか
な夏の終わりぐらいに私動画出しました8
月26日かこ衝撃かこすぎでバイクを買っ
たけどこの男まさかの笑笑笑笑まさかの
免許持っていない今10月末あれから
ちょうど2ヶ月ぐらい経ちました
本日10月26
日大バイクの免許を取得しまし
たよしよしよしよしよしよし免許取りまし
た大型バイクの免許自動大型2輪え排気量
制限なしえ私はめたち今え自動車の他にえ
バイクタイヤ2個ついてるやつ何でも乗れ
ます長かったいや長かったですあの話の
流れを説明するとあの僕ですね8月に出し
たバイクの動画でも言ってるんですけども
どうしても乗りたいバイクがあってそれ先
買っちゃったんですよ免許ないのに免許
ないのにNM402っていうもうなんか
あのアニメのアラのバイクみたいなアキラ
バイクって言われてるようななんかアニメ
みたいな金未来型バイクがどうしても乗り
たくてもう先に免許取りに行くよりバイク
を買ってしまって2ヶ月間ずっと俺んちに
買ったけど乗ることが許されないバイク
きっぱになってたんですけどもいつから
自動し学校行ったんだろう1ヶ月前ぐらい
から自動車学校に行き始めてようやく1
ヶ月かけて大型バイクの免許を撮ることが
できまし
たあのなんか教習所の自動車学校で動画と
か撮りたいなと思ったんですけどやっぱり
いろんな生徒さんたくさんいるので全く
動画撮らなかったんですけどたまに
ちょっとあのバイクの装備してる自分の
自撮り取ったりとかはしってたんですけど
あのこっそりとガシガシ隙間時間に1日1
時間でも2時間でもいいからこう行って
無事に大型免許のバイク取得することが
できました
はいいやもうねね大変でしたねやっぱり
大型バイクってなるとあのもう無制限なん
で全てのバイク乗れるようになるから結構
教習もねあのしっかりしてまして例えば
あの1本橋細い1本橋を何秒以上かけて
ゆっっくり割ったりってこのバランス取り
ながらとかスラロームっていうこの
ジグザグバシリこジグザグ行くのこの何秒
以内に渡れとかあの結構ちゃんと練習し
ないといけないような訓練を無事突破して
私バイクの免許シすることができました
今日からライダーですはいということで
免許ししてついにあのバイク乗ることが
できますいや長かったしあのバイクの卒業
検定っていう自動車学校で卒業検定という
あなたはもうバイク乗るに足りえます十分
な技術そして能力あと判断力とか交通
ルールをしっかり守ってえ行動で運転する
ことができますっていうその許可証みたい
なやつ取るのに試験があるんですけども
実際運転して乗ってやるやつそれに無事一
発で合格しました
ストレート
朝は落ちました一緒に行ってたサビ落ちて
しまいました明後日多分また受けに行くと
思うんですけどいやもうね
本当あんまこんなこと自分から言たくない
んですけど忙しいんですよ忙しくて全然
教習通えなくてやばい時2週間開いたりし
ててもう全部忘れちゃうんですよバイクと
は何かバイクのことすっかり忘れたりする
ぐらい開いたりもしたんですけども少しで
も時間があればバイクの教習詰めてなんと
か1ヶ月ちょいで本気出せば取ることが
できました久々に学校っていうものがいっ
てちょっと楽しかったです
ねなんか出会いとかないかなと思ったけど
ありませんでしたその卒業検定っていう
実際に乗る実のテストなんですけどもあの
ま中に落ちてる人もいましたで僕あの点数
聞いたところ具体的な点数はなんか言え
ないらしいので聞けなかったんですけども
あの100点近くという点数だったらしい
ですパーフェクトいやめちゃくちゃ真面目
に行かせていただいてもう免許取るため
だったら泥水もすする気持ちで感のいう
こと全て頭に叩き込んで緊張でちょっと何
個かミスあったのかもしれませんがもう
本当自分の中では絶対文句を言わせない
運転をして無事免許を取ることができまし
たであのごめんなさいあの動画これ撮る前
にも帰ってきた瞬間すぐバイクまたがって
ねちょっとだけドライブしてきたんですよ
その時のつをご覧ください
どうぞどうも免許取りましてえどんぐらい
置いてあったっけ2ヶ月ぐらい2ヶ月
ぐらい置いったよねはいえ2ヶ月間乗れ
なかったバイクただの鉄のだったバイクに
ようやく乗れることになりまし
たじゃ乗りますねもう早速お願いします
落ちたのにくそ乗らしてくれもだめですや
なかっ
た時間の合間をくぐっていってたからな
遅れちゃダメなのマジきついよねきつかっ
たす久々に30分前に行ってた集合
[音楽]
場所
よし
[音楽]
あやばいわ
えっとちょっと無理
だいや今教習だけだからマジで誰よりも
丁寧な運転します
よすすいません本当ちゃんと閉めないとね
バイクの芋はかっこよ
じゃあ初バイク初マイバイク行ってきます
お願いし
ます行きます
ねええ何なんで
あね
うわ
勝ちあマジでわから
ん
[音楽]
え
えり
[音楽]
ますやばい全然違う教習しとライトつい
てる
ついてますついてるよね
はい免許所
ない免許所ないやばい出たらもう捕まり
ますよ
危ねえギリ敷ないコンビニ行ってき
ます行きますうわ
怖い
[拍手]
[音楽]
あちいはいということでちょっと真っ暗で
よくわかんなかったです運転もあの怖かっ
たですけど安全に運転してきました明日
またちょっと明るい時にバイク乗りたいと
思いますいや良かっ
たはいというわけで後日ですいや天気が
めっちゃ良くて超バイクビリですねという
わけで早速この私のバイクNM402乗っ
ていきたいと思いますもう教習所でト習っ
たのでマジで安全運転で行ってき
ますかっこいいあ気づいたんですけど
なんか7年前にNM402のなんか優しい
解説動画出してる方がいて俺7年前にその
人の動画にコメントしてたんですよかっこ
いいて7年前から欲しかったみたいです
ちょっともう記憶にないけど7年越にり
たいバイに乗れるというちょっと夢みたい
な気分です乗り
[音楽]
[拍手]
ます
[音楽]
で
あはい
ただいま最高
あの本当に最高なんですよ実これ動画撮っ
てなかったらバイクから降りたくなくて
もう結構一生乗ってたいぐらい楽しいなん
だろうなんかもう車にはない本当爽快感と
楽しいというかもう何これ夢のマシンやな
いや大型バイクマジでいいな僕ずっと小型
バイク乗ってたんでそのバイクの楽しさは
知ってるなと思ってたんですけどもう全然
違う大型いナンバーワインザワールド
楽しいもうこの一言につきますでこのNM
402ってさなんかバイクというより
スクーターっぽいんですよどっちかという
とそのなんかバイクのギア変えてウェイ
みたいな感じじゃなくて楽に乗るバイクな
ので多分僕そんなスピードとか出せない
つもりですつもりです今のとこ高速道乗る
つもりもないしどっちかというとその
ちょっとした買い物とかちょっとうちの
近く行くかの時とかに乗ったりとか
あんまりスピード出すつもりなく使いたい
と思ってますでなんで俺こんな突然大型ブ
でこれ買おうかと思ったのかって言と
大きなきっかけが1つありましてアニメの
ゾン100ってみさん知ってますゾンビに
なるまでした100のことっていうゾンビ
アニメがあるんですけどそれの主人公が
世界がもうゾンビに支配されててもう
みんな周りの人とか人間がゾンビになって
いく中どうせゾンビに食われるぐらいだっ
たら死ぬ間に何でもやってやるぜっていう
すごい清々しい精神の主人公なんですけど
天堂明楽っていう主人公の彼を見てて
どうせ死ぬんだったらしたいこと全部やっ
ておこうって思って天堂あも大型バイクに
乗りたいっていうのがしたいことの中の1
つにあってなんかふと思いいしましてあ
そういえば俺大型バイクで乗りたいバイク
あったなと思ってもう大型バイクに乗り
たいじゃなくてこのバイクに乗りたいって
いうので今回バイクを買って免許を取り
ましたいいですか皆さん人は絶対死にます
人は絶対死ぬん
ですいつか必ず死にますそれがもういつ
死ぬかも分かりませんちしたら年取って
まだ全然先かもしれないし鳥うるさいな
ひょっとしたら年取って死ぬかもしれない
し突然明日交通事故で死ぬかもしれません
もちろん安全運転しますよ教習場で習い
ます超安全にバイクの運転しますけどもう
避けられない事故もあると思いますも本当
何がどうなっていつしのか分からないので
人生
ってだったらだったらもうしたいことを
全部やっとこうって思って結構時間かかり
ましたけど大型2輪の免許も取りに行って
乗りたかったバイクに今またがって乗っ
てるわけでございますいやなんかねそう
バイクってその危ないってよく言うじゃん
事故した時の死亡率とかもすごいし危ない
乗り物っって言うけどもでも乗りたい
じゃんそんなの怖かってたらバイクに乗れ
ないのでしいこと野郎精神をゾン100と
いうアニメで学び最近は行動力が上がった
気がしますしたいことをやろうっていう
気持ちで最近生きてるはいそんな感じで
はめ社長のバイク生活が始まりました
なんかねこのあの教習所に行く
と別のバイクも欲しくなった別のバイクも
欲しくなりましたしこれもめっちゃいいん
ですけどなんかねまたバイクっぽい動画と
かバイクの旅動画とかも取れたらいいなと
思いますというわけで初め長無事
に欲しいバイクに乗れましたじゃ
[音楽]
な